hello everyone and welcome to today's
live webinar the role of immune cells
and immune checkpoint in multiple
myeloma presented by natalie hider hana
ch PhD candidate University Hospital
Bonn Germany I'm Christie Joel of lab
rats and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is presented by lab roots and
brought to you by thermo Fisher
Scientific to learn more about our
sponsor please visit thermo Fisher comm
forward slash cell culture heroes now
let's get started today's webinar is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on that support tab
found at the top right of your
presentation window or use that ask a
question box to let us know you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and the software's
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab and follow the process to
obtain your credits I now present
today's speaker Natalie Haider Hornet
Natalie is currently a PhD student at
the department for oncology immunology
and hematology at the University
Hospital Bonn in Germany she is working
in the biomedical research laboratory
under the direction of Professor dr.
Peter bursar
her thesis focuses on immunotherapy in
multiple myeloma currently she
investigates the regulation of immune
cells and the expression of immune
checkpoint for example by using crystal
Cassadine technology and flow cytometry
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
welcome Natalie you may now begin your
presentation
yeah thank you very much for the kind
introduction
so my name is Natalie and yeah first I
want to thank you for giving me this
great opportunity to discuss our work
and of course I want to thank the
University Hospital bond and my PI for
the support okay so with that I want to
start the talk I would just mention that
it really brought overview of the topic
so if anybody has specific questions
please get in touch with us and I would
love to discuss the research in more
detail then
well let's start with the timeline of
historic events and cancer treatment
everything began with surgery where were
these treatments were not that accurate
and successful alone after the
development of radiotherapy in the early
1900 the treatment strategies were
essential improved by the discovery of
chemotherapy drugs around 1940 so these
are tied to drug cytotoxic drugs that
mainly aim to kill highly proliferative
cells such as cancer cells breakthrough
in the field of medical oncology was the
development of targeted therapy like
inhibitors or monoclonal antibodies
against acidic targets on the tumor so
this approach is much more directed and
therefore enables more effective tumor
cell killing and their side effects
the last turning point and modern
oncology took place in 2010 with the use
of immunotherapy particle poachers for
advanced and metastatic tumors so this
huge and promising fourth column of
cancer treatment was established by the
work of Ellison and hanji I think in the
90s and instead of targeting the tumor
cell itself
Nina therapy aims to boost the immune
system and restore its ability to
recognize and destroy the cancer cells
and one of the latest skip ko webinars
we heard also interesting lectures of
immunotherapy for example the approach
of using Uncle it aquarius's by Alex
Baker so today we want to focus a bit
more on the tumor immune
microenvironment and immune checkpoint
inhibitors
how does it come to tumor progression a
homeostatic new micro environment is
important to control any alteration
arising in the different tissue
compartments of the body so this
condition is termed as immunity violence
when all the different immune
subpopulations constantly control the
micro environment and respond to
targeted to any new upcoming event
cancer University describes the process
of shift from such and control
thermostatic immune micro environment to
immunosuppressive to more tolerant micro
environment this is because of a
progress in which immune cells grow
muscles and tumor cells in constant
interaction either by direct cell-cell
contact or because of their different
secreted cytokines and chemokines
profiles for the process of tumor cell
elimination it is of high importance
that the immune cells see and recognize
the malignant cells especially new
antigens which are substructures from
these transformed malignant host cells
or are important for this recognition
but when time goes by tumor cells adapt
they down regulate these antigens and
receptors that are recognized by the
immune cell and on the other hand they
also communicate them that they are
tolerable and not dangerous so this
state of tumor dormancy contributes to
the selection of tumors a variance with
highest capacities to survive like tumor
stem cells and finally the suppression
of the immune system and the survival of
the camp Cyclones Lister which are
fittest contributes to the tumors escape
mechanism
you
how does the human immune cell
interaction look like and more detail
for full activation of the t-cell which
are the main effector cells of the
adaptive immune system free signals are
actually necessary
so first the t-cell receptor recognizes
a specific antigen for example an
altered structure from the malignant
host cell so that the T cell receptor
engages with a major histocompatibility
complex receptor from either another
immune cell or an antigen presenting
cells are also from its tumor cell
itself as a control mechanism various
either co-stimulatory or Co inhibitory
receptors are then transiently
upregulated so the overall input of
these positive or negative signals then
determine determines the activation
state of the t-cell they can for example
develop into an effector Tisa or in
contrast into an immunosuppressive
regulatory t-cell and finally also the
cytokine secretion as a feedback loop
serves as a sign to nough for the t-cell
response like is it strong a weak
communication to surrounding cells and
so on
and although these co inhibitory signals
are quite important to mediate tolerance
and also prevent out in unity to mothers
often use these checkpoints to down
regulate the immune response so one
mechanism that tumor cells used to hide
and escape from the immune system is to
up regulate immune checkpoints like pd-1
and PDL 1 and therefore faciliate a
proteinogenic micro environment
so immunotherapy aims to boost the
immune system and restore the ability to
recognize council cells and kill them
here by a key to success of
immunotherapy is the ability of the
immune system to actually see the cancer
cell in solid tumors there is a large
discrepancy of immunotherapy politic
success described by the model of heart
versus call tumors so for example
melanoma is so called immunologically
hot tumor they are characterized by a
high mutational load and high production
of new antigens and therefore massive
infiltration of lymphocytes
so they were good for immunotherapy
party approaches which boosts the
anti-tumor immune response and for
example in combination with radio or
chemotherapy which aim to destroy the
targeted at the target cell and
consequently produce even more new
antigens that makes the tumor more
recognizable for the in himself and
increases the cancer cell killing
efficiency but in contrast a so called
immunological code tumors like
pancreatic cancer are protected by
surrounding stromal cells so they for
some reason don't provoke a strong
immune response and T cells are unable
to penetrate the tumor over mark these Q
must attract immunosuppressive cells
like t-rex or milo to have suppressor
cells that furthermore secrete cytokines
to down regulate immune response and as
we and as a result we get a so called
immune desert which is filtered around
the tumor
okay so let's come to the hematological
malignancies my PhD project is about you
know therapeutic approaches in multiple
myeloma therefore I'd like to give you a
brief overview of this malignancy
multiple myeloma is the tech most common
hematologic malignancy and of course and
at an average age of about 65 years and
it is still an incurable disease myeloma
the disorder of terminally
differentiated plasma cells
characterized by clonal expansion of
malignant plasma cell in the bone marrow
and a massive production of Union
globulin so these antibodies which are
also called para proteins have lost
their function and they don't recognize
any target structures or for example
invading pathogens or ever and hosters
anymore
instead they accumulate and so these
uncontrolled proliferation of
unfunctional plasma cells replaces the
normal healthy hematopoietic cells in
the bone marrow the so called Krabbe
criteria are essential for the
diagnostic of myeloma
so first elevated calcium level are
caused by the altered bone mission
metabolism which we've increased bone
resorption and then there is an impact
kidney function which arises because of
the massive production of mono canal
immune globulins in the blood the
kidneys try to filter these antibodies
but the accumulation of the spare
proteins increased with the disease
progression also enemy and infections
are problem because of the infiltration
of the tumor cells in the bone marrow
that suppress the normal hematopoiesis
and finally main difficulties are made
by the bone lesions so the bone material
is not static it is actually a constant
progress of bone resorption by Rabbi the
osteoclasts
resort material and that there are Co
blasts gained the bone material
and the bone pain of myeloma patient has
mainly increased due to the many due to
the increased osteoclast Genesis during
this program
so the initial genetic event is thought
to occur in the germinal center of the
lymph nodes where b-cells major
fascinated by somatic hypermutation and
isotype switching a founder clone arises
and due to the novel mutations time by
time this disease progresses to first
still as a somatic state called
monoclonal gammopathy of undetermined
significance which is M gas and then
proceeds to smoldering myeloma and
finally to the symptomatic myeloma so a
main feature of this disease is to
hydrate heterogeneity represented in
these different chaplains making the
patient treatment much challengeable at
the bottom of the slide you can see
general biological events typical for
the disease progression like in other
cancer types the tumor cells become more
aggressive and the tumor
microenvironment
shifts to a tumor friendly surrounding
but typical for myeloma as mentioned is
that the outer edge bone metabolism
okay don't be scared because of this
full slide is actually one of my
favorite so in the corner you can see
some of the typical hallmarks of cancer
the accurate bone metabolism was
increased Austria tested Genesis leading
to the typical bone lesions mentioned at
the mention at the lab upper left sorry
he's acknowledging axis here is the rank
rank of ignorant pathways in contrast
increased vascularization is a quite
common hallmark of cancer the
accelerated proliferation of cancer
cells is linked to an increased
metabolism and the need of malnutrition
and oxygen is also common hallmark and
this adaption associated by neo ng new
angiogenesis
the formation of new but also Wheaton
dot vessels the alteration of the tumor
stroma microenvironment you can see it
in the corner on the left hand side is a
key for the development of cancer
similar to the immune cells this tumor
cells in constant contact with the tumor
cells communicate and influence each
other
so also the extracellular matrix of the
south changes and they begin to secrete
proteomic genic factors like survival
factors growth factors and other
stimulated cytokine so we want to focus
on the shift from an anti tumor tumor
tolerant micro environment as mentioned
previously the up regulation of immune
checkpoint checkpoint contributes to the
tumor immune escape mechanisms
sorry in the case of myeloma the pd-1 PA
1 means program to f1 and program their
flight of one signalling axis is
especially critical and there are
different immune checkpoint inhibitors
and clinical trials but they are not
sufficient as monotherapy
okay and in the center you can see this
pinkish malignant as Marcel and
surrounded different treatment
modalities on going to the to target the
myeloma bone a varnish and the
first-line therapy strategies today the
combination or what I hope I pronounce
it right is not sorry dexamethasone with
different numeral Atari drugs like
linearly divided and proteasome
inhibitor aborted some up well for the
case of advanced stage diseases like
relapse and refractory cases there are
clinical trials for the combination of
these drugs and boosting them with
different
immunotherapy party strategies like
monoclonal antibodies mediating
for example antibody dependent
cytotoxicity or different vaccination
strategies using dendritic cells so as
patients with advanced disease stage so
high up regulation of pd-1 and PDL 1 and
bone marrow and black tissue samples we
want to focus on this indian checkpoint
so myeloma is still incurable and
monetary particle proaches are not
sufficient
therefore we aim to find a beneficial
immunotherapy particle approach based on
immune checkpoint in addition these
immunotherapy otic approaches can be
divided into three different strategies
agents that boost the immune response by
blocking and reversing immunosuppressive
pathways like immune checkpoint in
addition or are drugs that specifically
target the malignant clone for example
receptors that are only expressed on a
tumor cells and then mediate
cytotoxicity like monoclonal antibodies
targeting PC ma or slammer seven on the
malignant clone are very personalized
and promising cellular based therapy
approaches we're mostly autologous
immune cells are modified to achieve a
much higher anti tumor response like in
car tea or car NK cell therapy
you
so as mentioned the pd-1 and PDL one
immune checkpoint is upregulated in
myeloma patient samples of advanced
disease stage which make this pathway to
a promising target during the immune
cell tumor cell interaction it is not
only the problem that these Co
inhibitory receptor transiently down
regulate the immune response in a state
of chronic inflammation similar to a
chronic viral infection the immune cells
became exhausted that means they are
constantly low activated but are not
responding in a proper way anymore and
instead become apoptotic after a while
so you can see in this illustration that
if the T cell becomes in contact to
tumor cell by the antigen presentation
the up regulation of pd-1 abrogates the
downstream t-cell receptor signaling
pathway and instead of producing
pro-inflammatory cytokines like I won t
and F or interference they start to
secrete immunosuppressive cytokines like
until our key intent
therefore they not only differentiate
into an energy exhausted and
immunosuppressive phenotype they also
influence the tumor microenvironment
with these Protima cytokine may you so
in my PhD project we aim to knock out
the signaling pathways and in sorry and
to investigate the influence of other
immune and Jamaat's out
to do so we work with the mouse myeloma
cell and five T free free which is which
not only enables in vitro studies also
there's an established mouse model with
the use of the stair line so this five T
free free Mouse myeloma cell and
strongly expresses PDL 1 and we use the
CRISPR cast 9 technology to delete this
gene there are many different methods to
deliver the CRISPR plasmid into the
target cell
but as this 5 t through free thoughts
our suspension cells electroporation
seems to be the most efficient way for
the transaction at the bottom you can
see the organization of a typical Chris
podcast locals in a microbial genome so
crisper loci contain a combination of
CRISPR associated genes called cast
then the endonucleases and as well
non-coding RNA elements which enabled a
specifically which offering nucleic
acids
the mechanism of the CRISPR class system
can be divided into three stages so
first in the acquisition acquisition
stage sorry the concept calf and the
nucleus complex acquires a specific
sequence the protostrator from the
foreign invader DNA and integrators as a
new spacer into the CRISPR rate which
then later serves as the immunological
memory text and the expression stage the
CRISPR array is transcribed into a
peculiar are named transcript that is
further processed into small units of
RNA known as crispr RNA so these crisp
RNAs are combined with the calf protein
to form the active cars CRISPR and a
river nuclear protein complex wherever
the crisp RNA functions now as a guide
for the
endonuclease to identify complementary
structures and third in the interference
stage the crispr RNA Castroville nuclear
protein complex through network then
scans the cell for you for enucleate asa
targets which are recognized by
complementary base pairing and a
successful recognition then leads to the
cleavage and degradation of the target
nucleic acid so the guide RNA determines
where the insertions or deletions and
the gene will occur and once the guide
RNA and calf nine protein are expressed
in the cell the guide RNA would direct
the class nine to bind the target
sequence and introduce a double strand
break the cell can then repair the break
either with non-homologous end joining
always homology directed repair
mechanisms non-homologous end joining is
the most active repair mechanism but
often leads to inversions or deletions
near the target sequence if these
so-called Indians occur within an open
reading frame it may introduce a
frameshift that causes a premature stop
codon
eliminating the gene function therefore
it might be beneficial to add a homology
directed repair template
to enable specific gene repair and
furthermore these homology directed
repair plasmids can contain additionally
for example reporter gene read flute and
reporter gene are resistant against
antibiotics like paralyzing so enabling
better cell selection but to be honest
especially for suspension cells it's
very hard to achieve such a core
infection so we continued our work with
the 50-50 PDA one knock out such cells
which are already transfused with GFP
okay now what to do with this immunitech
translocate in our lab we use that cell
line to characterize the myeloma cell
independence of the PDL 1 signaling axis
the behavior on the different drug
treatment and of course we also want to
investigate the tumor immune cell
interaction but the most exciting part
is to be continued as that fascinating
research is still in progress and we are
looking forward to present you our
interesting findings and the next
applications so that I would like to
highlight the work of this working group
which analyzed the tumor numeric
environment during myeloma disease
progression using the 5 T for free
myeloma mouse model they nicely show
that the amount of pd-1
positive cd4 and cd8 t-cells increases
with the amount of PDL positive plasma
cells in the bone marrow and in the
spleen of to mobilize and furthermore
these pd-1 positive t-cells
additionally co-expressed other immune
checkpoint in this case Tim free and
we're also partly apoptotic compared to
the healthy control so this working
group did also functional assays with
these exhausted immune cells and
identified the loss of effector cell
function and an increased
immunosuppressive phenotype measured by
the altered cytokine secretion so these
findings as the base gives insight into
a very complex highly regulated human
new microwave
and hints that there are many more other
alterations doing the disease
progression to be identified
with this augment I want to close my
talk and I wish any researchers also
working out on the optimization of
cancer treatment all the best of luck
okay so in summary we learned how the
tumor cells will influence their
surrounding stroma and immune Mike
environment and we can even cause cancer
mutating leading to a tumor escape and
we clarified the function of immune
checkpoint like pd-1 and signaling axis
on which t-cell responses are modulated
followed by the development of t-cell
exhaustion and furthermore we focused on
multiple myeloma which is still an
incurable disease with high need of new
treatment modalities td1 and PDL one is
highly appreciated in patients of
advanced disease states immune
checkpoint inhibitors and clinical
trials but they are not sufficient as
monotherapy
and instead we need a combination with
other strategies to boost the immune
system and to more make make the tumor
cells more visible for the immune system
and we talked about the microworld
defense system CRISPR cos which is
mediated by three different steps
acquisition expression and interference
and this is a system which makes us
possible to delete and insert any gene
of interest and finally we talked about
the identification of cell surface
markers and cell populations using solar
thermal tree and mouse myeloma models
using five T free free cells
you
okay and this is the literature I used
but there are many other great
populations for this exciting field of
research
okay and with this I want to thank my
working group my supervisor it is such a
great time I'm very thankful for the
opportunity to work in this lab with
this great people and actually I almost
learn everyday so thanks to unit one and
of course Thank You Kip girl for giving
me this nice opportunity to talk about
our research field
yeah last but not least thank you so
much for listening especially because it
was a really broad talk and very happy
to discuss any more details with you so
please feel free to ask questions and
keep in touch thank you very much
Thank You Natalie for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of our webinar now to our
audience if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen and we will
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for okay let's get started so
we have some great questions already
coming in now leave let's start with
this one how do we achieve a better
cancer treatment in the future yeah this
is of course a very good question
and I'm sure if not all the answers but
one part is definitely the development
to personalized medicine so as surgery
chemotherapy and radiotherapy are
working like the model of one drug fits
all the use of cancer immunotherapy is
much more personalized to the individual
tumor so while cytotoxic drugs aim to
kill just highly proliferate yourself
immunity particle proaches boost the
patient's own immune system with a
variety of targets so precision medicine
aims to diagnose actually disease before
it's clinically outbreaks so that the
treatment can start as early as possible
to control the disease but for this
approach of course the diagnostic
methods has to be very improved like all
the comics studies but I think the
development is growing more and more
into this direction but it's quite
complicated
of course to generate all these data
like finding biomarkers for the diseases
and we not only have to do a lot of
clinical studies to find these markers
also use these yeah big data and the
right wave and in general I think the
strategies for hamato logical
malignancies seems to be that there's a
tendency of yeah more like three
treatment strategies are better than two
or in the future I don't know maybe far
better than free so monitor particle
purchase are mostly because of the high
redundancy not that effective yeah this
is I think in general the tandem seems
and for example as specific party is
mentioned
turning cold tumors like prostate cancer
to more illogical hot tumors will also
be a challenge because of the
trafficking and homing of the immune
cells that actually cannot reach this
tumors so if that could be improved I
think it's going to be much better than
Thank You Natalie and here's another
great question what is car t-cell
therapy is it already in use yes so
called teaser therapy is a type of
adaptive cell therapy using engineer
t-cells to specifically target a
receptor highly expressed on a tumor
cells so these cells have a chimeric
antigen receptor which consists of the
t-cell receptor of course that
recognizes a target and it is also
included an intracellular activation
availa or I think CD free and cd28 so
that the full activation of this t-cell
is all the time
active and enables the target cell
killing without any MHC molecule so I
think it's also already in use for
example for myeloma ARL CLL but as far
as I know only for a refractory or
ellipse patients yeah so for example in
in b-cell lymphomas cd38 and cd19 are
often targets for the car T cells then
directly kill especially these cells but
of course also and healthy tissue
expresses these markers so there's some
kind of risk are also developing
resistance but yeah this is already
showing promising effects so basically
the T cells have the specific a of
antibodies the sector function of
cytotoxic T cells but are not dependent
on other stimuli and then target of the
target and not prune for
immunosuppressive mechanisms by the
tumor microenvironment
now Natalie are there other immune cells
that are regulated by immune checkpoint
besides T lymphocytes absolutely so the
function of immune checkpoints on T
cells is much best known on years like
cd4 and cd8 t-cells but for example also
MKT that are tightly regulated by Co
inhibitory receptors but although they
are function is actually completely
different so for example in case our
skin surrounding cells for their MHC
expression pattern and if they cannot
detect the MHC complex they only say our
killer cells function so this mechanism
enables them the differentiation between
self and non-self and/or for example on
effector unaffected t-cells by viruses
for example and they're responsible
receptor for this is the key receptor
which is also cool inhibitory receptor
so but also other checkpoints like p1
and I note CTL forty good investor
regulate in paid cell function and of
course they are also checkpoint
inhibitors under investigation also
interestingly immunosuppressive cells
like t-rex and my litter express
ourselves also expressed inhibitory
receptors so yes it's a general oval
phenomenon now we have you identified
the genes that you would introduce or
delete to increase the chance of
remission and there are not so far this
is really a good question but yeah it's
it's not very easy to identify of course
always we look for these genes which are
highly up regulated during the disease
and we focus on PD one PA one pathway
but
for this for example next generation
sequencing could help and sex training
so flow cytometry analyzes for this
receptor which are upregulated but yeah
we have we are looking on this and we
have to see but it's an interesting
point and I cannot explain it yet
because the publication is not here
Thank You Natalie now our next question
does hypoxia play a role in myeloma or
the treatment oh yeah absolutely
so while in solid tumors hypoxia is due
to the increased proliferation and tumor
growth and we're near angiogenesis
mostly promotes in diffusion weakened
blood vessel formation the oxygen level
rings below no Maxia and this is only
for the solid tumors but in case of the
myeloma the boomer itself is hypoxic
nice
so then myeloma cells constantly
activate for example have one alpha and
therefore the hypoxia responsible genes
can promote survival resistant and
proliferation and the tumor cells can
grow but in contrast the T cells like
effector T cells and cannot live within
this hypoxic level actually interesting
not because only of the less oxygen more
because of the Exedy pH and they cannot
adapt so the T cells go into apoptosis
and instead municipal cells like T Rex
are stimulated so this is really a point
in myeloma and the trick is that there
are hypoxic as emphasis drugs which are
not working on the my marceia they say a
suit pro drug and and I in hypoxia they
convert into their cytotoxic form and
therefore mainly destroys the tumor cell
there
Thank You Natalie now here's an
interesting question in your opinion is
there any scenario where immunotherapy
could cause a kind of autoimmune
condition or disease mmm absolutely this
is a point so whether it is immune
checkpoint inhibitor or car t-cell
therapy there can always be some adverse
effects there so if we block the immune
checkpoint which are responsible for
self tolerance of course there's the
risk that the immune cells the immune
system targets
itself so if it's already been described
that some patients which God I think it
was in jackpot inhibition also develop
rheumatological diseases like arthritis
and yeah this is always a risk also the
cytokine release syndrome which is a
systemic strong inflammatory response
can cause similar diseases so yeah this
happened indeed but the treatments are
going better and better and it's more
possible to predict such diseases so
it's still a risk but yeah it's
developing in a good direction I think
Thank You Natalie now our next question
is two parts so I'm going to read the
whole question and we can answer it part
by part and we have a question coming in
from Sebastian here Natalie's thank you
for this comprehensive overview I
actually have two questions maybe I did
not get it during your talk number one
how about metastasis in human logic
entities is it possible or can it be
described in a different way and also
are there forms of metastasis known in
multiple myeloma
you mentioned osteoblasts and
osteoclasts thank you very much
okay sorry yeah so the the point of
metastasis in Hemet elliptical diseases
so we we know that in solid tumors of
course they the cancer cells need to
transform so during the progress of EMT
mat formation which is a apt amazing
tumor transition they stomata just have
first have to gain capabilities to
migrate and beef their primary teacher
so the first steps of migration invasion
in interpretation into the blood
lymphatic system this is obviously and
not necessary for hematological tumors
as they are already circulating in the
blood but yes the other step as far as I
know are quite comparable so in the
vascularity system the tumor cells have
to escape from the unit X which is one
point and at the distant side the need
to excavate into the new tissue and in
case of a metal helmet electrical cancer
cells these are often secondary lymphoid
organs like spleen lymph nodes may be
the liver and yes it's their natural
function actually for generating immune
responses they don't need a lot of
mutations to a cry of such a function
but it is still I think a critical step
as in solid tumors to adapt at secondary
sites to build new colonies and
different microgram and so I can imagine
em it is kind of metastases yes quite
comparable and what was the second
question
yeah if the tumor cells destroy the
bones itself so well actually it's more
in indirect effect so a hallmark of
myeloma is the increased a student class
activity normal cases are to cast a
resort the bone material and osteoblast
for
the growth so this is a they are
regulating itself and via the rank
record signaling pathway and in myeloma
this is a really disruptive progress and
the the myeloma cells activate this
radio signaling and promote the
osteoclast Genesis and as a consequence
the the bone material is destroyed and
this leads to the secretion of growth
factors and also like insects which in
turn stimulates the myeloma cell
proliferation so this is like a bad
feedback loop and interestingly also I
think monocytes and macrophages can be
also stimulated by this rank rankle OPG
signaling pathway and further
differentiate into a third class also
worsening this cycle of active duty bone
lesion so it's really a and yet in
direct effect of the myeloma sub
Thank You Natalie now we have a question
coming in from Roma and she would like
to know if you could tell us more about
t-cell exhaustion in this instance um
pedimos didn't get it
sure can you tell us more about t-cell
exhaustion in this instance
and I can not understand what it is
symptoms the last word sorry ah
in this relevance in this instance in
this example
okay so you mean and the PD one PD
League and one pathway melanoma or what
is actually the focus so em exhaustion
of t-cells is step further than just
being down regulated so it is normal
that the receptor the co hibbity
receptors up regulated and then down
regulate the immune response right and
just as they are constantly down
regulated like in viral infections or in
the tumor progression these continuously
up regulation of Kuran hibbity receptors
and leading to the exhaustion and this
is an anarchic state where the t-cells
don't even respond to anything anymore
and instead they go into apoptosis you
know so they are not only down regulated
they die more or less after this stage
so yeah this is actually theory
Thank You Natalie we have so many great
questions coming in we only have time
for one more question and I do want to
remind our audience that those questions
we do not have time to answer today and
additionally those questions that are
submitted during the on-demand period
they will be addressed by the speaker
via the email address that you provided
at the time of your registration okay
Natalie wrapping with this question how
specific is immunotherapy is it really
safe and what are the risks yeah well we
already come to this point so it is more
or less specific as we always try to
find a target which is mainly expressed
on the tumor cell right but always like
in b-cell leukemia say for example
myeloma where the target cells the
plasma cell these markers like BCM a or
cd38 are also expressed on the healthy
cells and sometimes on the surrounding
tissue so as already said there's always
the risk of on target but of tumor
effects so they say and yeah this is why
it is to be optimized and we are still
searching for more specific targets but
at least there's always a risk to
develop yeah like the cytokine release
syndrome any other problematics
features that a target the healthy
tissue of the patient
Thank You Natalie I mean thank you for
today's Q&A this was great very detailed
answers do you have any final comments
for our audience hmmm
well actually just saying thank you
thank you
typical lab routes and demo fish' for
this nice communication platform so I
think it's very important to communicate
the science not only to connect those
scientists also to connect with the
world and I think it's a very good idea
and yeah thanks a lot
also for those nice questions they are
very not that easy but very intelligent
Thanks
thank you again to our Natalie hider
cottage for her time today and for very
important research now I would like to
thank lab roots but I also want to thank
our sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific or
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event you will now be redirected to
our next cell culture heroes webinar the
role of sirt1 lxr signaling and diabetic
retinopathy presented by Sandra hammer
research fellow Michigan State
University this webinar will broadcast
live on December 17th at 9:00 a.m.
Pacific time we hope to see you there
and bye for now and have a great day